welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm very excited to be joined by
blaine dawes
who is the co-founder of wanted who are
a professional search partner that
operate in the technology space
which he launched in april this year
with his business partner cole
before this blaine has worked in the
industry for over a decade
working his way up from consultant to a
head of
division position and along the way has
achieved several
top biller of the year achievements
before launching his
very own agency this year blaine thank
you for joining me
no no it's good good to be part of the
podcast i've been a
been a subscriber for a while now so
it's good to finally be able to
subscribe to to guest so where i always
like to start is
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think make up a highly
successful
recruitment consultant yeah i think
there's two key ones for me the first
one is
every morning having a healthy mind and
the second thing
is being resilient because the job's
tough at times and you've just got to
keep
knocking away and with it so they're the
two key things for me
tell me more about this healthy mind
that's interesting curious yeah yeah
it's a healthy mind
being just to start the day fresh with
coming into the office leaving any
worries
with you at home i always say to all of
my team or even myself
just i get up in the morning look in the
mirror say look what do i want to
achieve today
and just walk out the door with just a
clean mind because
if you bring things into work with you
and
everyone gets stressed at times job
family
everything else especially with the
times that we're having at the moment
it can really distract you and i'm just
a big believer in
you know healthy mind is key and just
leaving all that stuff behind you just
starting fresh
because every day is a new day being
present love that
exactly yeah yeah yeah where just just
let's just focus on this for a second
because i i love the fact
that you've got you've that's one of
your core attributes that you think
for success so i guess where has this
come from blaine because i'm i'm sure
this you haven't always had a healthy
mind right so
how where where have you cultivated that
from or why has that become so important
for you
yeah for me i mean um i went through
challenging times through my life and
you know there's different things you
know being a young dad and
a dad you know that i was never planning
to have a child or anything like that so
you know
how old was you um so i was 24
and wow because my son is five now so
yeah
um it was it was early and uh me and my
wife we just wasn't wasn't planning that
and then it was when i was like pretty
much just starting
my my career properly in search um and
we didn't have
you know a property we were renting
and having a child was so unexpected and
i learned early
on is um you know there was lots of
financial challenges lots of other
challenges
and that every young person goes through
and
for me it was about you know tracking my
success but just making sure
that my mind at all times was in a was
in a clear state
um and that was the the key and you know
i done really well from having that
and i've that's been a rule now that i
literally just put into my book that
you know it's so important just to just
have a clear mind because you can be so
distracted nowadays by the media
or or anything going on and the problem
is you can easily get down by that and
it's easier said than done
but you've really got to be disciplined
and just keep your mind
healthy whether that's exercising in the
morning so i get up in the morning and
go for a long run
or a bike ride or or maybe it's you know
watching something because everyone has
different drivers for me it's just about
getting up and getting out the door and
running
and taking my mind off of stuff um
and and and real just just just last
thing on this because i find this
really interesting is so if i'm
listening right now and i'm that i know
that's maybe a weakness of mine
or i i do find it hard to have that
clarity in mind or i am easily
distracted or i don't have a
sort of um i don't have that mindset
towards
starting a new day yeah as you said yeah
distractions or
external influences that i can't control
that might be affecting me
if that's family if that's or see life
what's going on right now
yeah just it's if i'm feeling really if
i feel like my mind's more
more cluttered and i'm finding difficult
to be present like what would your
advice
maybe three best bits of advice for me
to get closer to having more of the
mindset that you're talking about
they're clearly yeah yeah for sure
i think the first thing is and it might
sound stupid is just
take a breath you know take a deep
breath um
and just uh evaluate things around you
you know what's positive
focus on the positives um if you can
train the brain to just
get the negatives away and just have the
positives and breathe
you know because a lot of people get
panicked and anxiety and stuff like that
and most of it is is down to breathing
just take a deep breath
think of positive things but also you
know sometimes just just look around you
and just
be grateful for kind of what you have
and so many people just
want more want more want more and
there's pressures in
and work but also i think it's so
important to have
two people around you that you can talk
to at any time
um whether that's professional or
or family but just have two key people
that you can just pick the phone up to
and just if you need to just literally
just get everything
out of you they're there as a sounding
board and if you've got that then it
really does help if you haven't again
you know just try and find someone
there's always people out there
and i'm always open to being one of them
them people as well if someone needs a
sound involved that's listening that
can't get that healthy mind
yeah i love that do you meditate i i
haven't done the meditation
thing um i've got friends that do do it
um
i'm just interested because you went to
the breath which obviously yeah yeah
yeah exactly i know um i haven't done it
massively um i've done different
training exercises
with breathing which you could say is a
form of meditation
um but um yeah and i haven't got deep
into it
because uh but i know that can really
help as well but maybe that's uh
on the to-do list next year i love that
that's awesome
okay so let let's start on unpacking
this journey then blame because
obviously so you launched
the recruitment business your own
recruitment business in april this year
yeah so um obviously in in um
challenging times and the strange times
yeah but obviously there's a lot of
things that you achieved before then
right so
i'm definitely keen to talk to you about
what gave you the confidence to take the
leap in these things sure
very quickly um like how would you
describe
the beginning of your recruitment career
uh
rocky yeah
yeah um i mean i i didn't know what to
expect i mean i
i came from like a new business
background
um within technology but i was selling
to
different infrastructure companies so i
had an understanding of technology
um but i didn't i didn't know how to put
sort of bums on seats for example
in recruitment and so i had to learn
that from scratch tonight to learn that
really quickly because like i say
um i was uh told i was gonna be a dad
about six months into my recruitment
career so it was like i needed to learn
fast
um but i learned the thing with
recruitment was
um you can easily over complicate the
process
and it's just about sticking to you know
a methodology
um that that you think works
um and just sticking to it and not going
off course
because recruitment's quite simple if
you stick to
just the things that is important uh you
can easily get
sidetracked with different technology
tools these days and different things
but if you just stick to the process i'm
a big believer stick to a process that
works and you'll get the results you
want
and don't deviate from the process
sometimes create new
processes in it but it's not just a one
or two
trick pony in recruitment i think you've
got to have different different ways of
working with different clients
so what what what if if you could go
back and speak to
blaine who just found out he's going to
be a dad first in recruitment
yeah what would you say to him uh
brief um
no i think i think the key thing was i
was surrounded by
good billers in my last company um
everyone was
a lot older a lot mature than me so
average age within that business
was about 30 years old which is
obviously quite old
and it was very much a traditional
search business so
for me i don't think i would have done
much
differently because i progressed really
quickly but i think the reason why i
progressed
quickly is that i surrounded myself by
good people they had a good process that
i learned and i stuck to
um and i think it's just all about being
sort of disciplined and
really just you know understanding you
know
what drives candidates what drives
clients really getting into the needs
of those candidates and clients and
really qualifying and
not being afraid to lose business
because i think a lot of
consultants they just want to win
everything and sometimes anything
and i think sometimes it's better if
you're more selective
in the types of clients the types of
candidates you work with
and just being open and honest if you
can't help someone just let them know
and feedback's critical i just make sure
that every candidate
that i'm working with i'm always feeding
back to them and
and also giving them guidance about
what went wrong in the process now i
know that's harder
for maybe if you're doing mass mass
recruitment at scale that's probably
difficult
um where a lot of my work is retained
or exclusive i can easily sit here and
say
well you know that's what i do with my
candidates i can understand if you're
running
20 jobs and it's one consultant then you
can be overworked
and it's hard to do that okay
so just just to frame this up a bit then
so from what i saw online so you've
worked before you
set up wanted you worked at two
companies yes right
yeah so before before you set up your
own agency you progressed to the
uh being a head of division and was it
like eight people you had on your team
yeah yeah so um when i left there was
around
eight people and i was a shareholder
within the business as well
and it was the best performing practice
for three years running and it was
the practice that had the least amount
of experience as well
because ie i was running it because the
people that did work in the business
they were great guys but they'd been
there for over 10 years
each of the the practice leads um so
they had a
pretty much triple the amount of
recruitment experience that i had
and you managed them no no so they were
so there was so we done so i run the
data center and ai division another guy
from
uh science oh sorry the other problem is
performing practice for three years
right so let's just let's just unpack
that a bit and then we'll we'll dig into
the um you being a business owner and
what you've learned
yeah yeah definitely yeah sure so
firstly so
obviously like it's just interesting the
words that you use right calling it
practice and and obviously a lot of the
things that you do
is is mainly searched it's retained so
like for anyone listening right
there'll be a lot of agency recruiters
that listen to this and and there will
be people that listen to this that do
work retained or it might just be
exclusive um but they'll definitely be
people that may want to
do more attend as well so yeah i haven't
had many
recruiters on here that um sort of
articulate or
say yeah i worked for a search practice
right it's a recruitment
that's what people call it right so in
your own words then like
how what what is the main difference of
you going i work for a search practice
rather than me saying i work for a
recruitment agency
yeah it's a really good question and
it's it's borderline because
they are very similar and it's just the
level
you operate at so typically i'm working
with c-suite
so you know cio cio vp of sales etc
yeah most of them people aren't
actively looking for a job um some of
them don't even have linkedin believe it
or not
um and you know it's just about
really really going deep undercover the
client
necessarily who's looking it's
probably normally that they're replacing
someone that don't know they're getting
replaced at a senior level
they cannot they cannot advertise the
role directly
and they cannot be seen to even be doing
this
so you you're like a very very good
detective
and you're kind of just going under the
radar
normally under a non-disclosure
agreement
and they will expect because of the fees
that you charge typically is anywhere
between
20 and 30 percent of total package they
expect a very good service for that
and you would get a short list of say
10 people and you would narrow that down
to five
you'd meet all of those candidates face
to face you'd take them through
an interview briefing session before
presenting them to the client
um normally that's done either face to
face or
virtually nowadays on teams
and then from there you know you you're
getting a payment so
normally typically the way a retainer
would work
is obviously it's a third up front you
know a third on short list
of the five candidates and a third on
the
candidate starting um and that's
typically how it works
now i suppose the language of
people that work in search and work in
recruitment is quite different as well
that's probably just down to the level
you're operating at the people you're
speaking with
but also the level of service you're
you're providing
um sometimes you know in my old business
and even with wanted we do psychometric
testing
um on certain leadership roles if it's
needed
and the client wants that um and
typically
when we go out to market or there's a
bid that comes up
um say for example i don't know x
is looking for a ceo or a vp of sales
you know we're going to be coming up
against management consultancies
russell reynolds corn ferry some of
these other
smaller boutique search businesses as
well and we're not coming up against or
say michael page or reed for example
so i suppose it is very different um
in in that sense um yeah because
we're not just in a big pool full of
sort of psls
typically the client will have a psl but
then they have an exec search partner
um and that psl do a lot of the volume
work
the search partners may only do four or
five hires
yeah interesting so the next thing i'll
ask you about
is is the retained piece but they're
very quickly blame
yeah there'll be a lot of people that
listen to this that that do want to do
more senior appointments
because they recognize i guess it's not
it's not just oh yeah it means i can
earn more money it's actually the things
you're talking about that actually
there's that perception of service right
there's something that comes up with
that the the client expects it and and
as a
as a good recruiter that's what you want
to go above and beyond
on that service rather than yeah maybe
always being involved in that
sort of lower level end where it is more
transactional on these things right
so how how did blaine late 20s
whatever age you were deal with i guess
the potential self-doubt of dealing with
c-suite dealing with
these oh typically they're always all
going to be older obviously but
i think that's a really interesting
thing if you think of uh typically
recruiters and i was one of these people
at the beginning of their career put
clients on the pedestal
let alone going into search firm and
dealing only with the c-suite and the
senior people would be so easy i guess
to fall into that so i guess
how did young blaine deal with that did
you have to deal with the self-doubt on
that how was that journey because i feel
like that
is something that people have to
overcome when they want to sort of
transition to
the more senior appointments in their
space yeah sure
i i i did it by really gaining
a knowledge of the client's business i
always said that
um to do a good job for my clients i
need to kind of
be like a candidate that would get a job
in with that client so i'd always like
read their latest press releases
look at their financial reports look at
the change
that's happened within their business
and talk about that change
i i very rarely talk about recruitment
it's really interesting i just typically
talk about
how their business is going you know
what their growth plans are
you know what sort of product lines
they're looking to launch um
if i can be of any assistance so i try
and be
a partner to all of these companies and
i think that was the key thing for me
and you probably noticed yeah i'm gonna
do date center world
next year in frankfurt i've spoke at a
lot of like tech conferences
where the subject isn't really
recruitment it's
normally like tackling the skill
shortage how can we get
more talent into the sector for example
it's not about you know okay well these
this is how i can help you recruit
off the back of them shows you don't
normally get much recruitment business
from it either
but what you do get is a name to be
known in the industry and i think
that's what i did really well was being
that sort of go-to person within the
data center market
but you've got to find a niche and you
need to be a specialist within it
and you've got to have references to
back you up so
i see a lot of people coming through the
ranks and
i look on their linkedin and you know
they don't hardly have any
recommendations or anything like that
and but i think definitely in exec
search
you you've got to have c level
references visible
and because it gets to a stage as well
where the industry is a little bit
biased you know it's not what you know
it's who you know
eventually um so basically what helped
you
i guess it was you being really curious
then and and
sort of exactly yeah not not going into
these calls or relationships
feeling like you have to know everything
because you're doing this it's your job
to
be you guys ask the right questions and
find out what their actual business
problems are and
okay so so okay let's just talk about
the
because they should talk about the
retained piece really quick
yeah because like what was what was the
average deal size for you then
so average deal size um at the moment i
was just doing my stats for the years
40k
this year really wow yeah because what's
been because obviously yeah what
obviously you said
practice the three um times year
and the biggest performing whatever
what's been your best year then as a
search consultant
anyone so billing wise my best year
just me personally um was without any
results or anything underneath me was uh
385
right and that was place in eight people
[Laughter]
that's that's a crazy thing i think
yeah eight meals in a year yeah yeah
yeah
it was eight deals um obviously
large large deals um but again you know
when you're
charging you know 30 that was what it
typically was um of package um
and these packages three four hundred
thousand
it's not too hard to do
in in the search world as well that's
not that big i make you laugh i won't
say the name but i actually
was going to go and join a big search
business
and i was in interview with a guy from
italy and had been there for 22 years
he was a really great guy and i told him
what i built
and he said to me yeah that's not very
good
i said i thought it was amazing right
coming from where i was but it wasn't
very good in his world and he said look
you know well our average search
consultant builds you know 1.2 million
and our top performing billing the us is
doing 4.2 million it was and i was like
wow um and then i i just
was like wow i'm a bit of a little fish
now
i thought it was a lot but it wasn't
like for me
like just so like what's the average
like
process length then of that because that
must be long as well
yeah i mean the longest deal i've done
was
it was about four and a half months from
start start to finish
but what what typically how long how
typically it's about three months
uh right a search should take
um so we i did a retain
retainer in april and the candidates
sort of started around
august time and and that was sort of
like a
very senior science i think that that's
a that's a that's a whole that's a sort
of
just different dynamic isn't it like
sort of doing all the things that you
need to do during that time and it's
just
typically longer and stuff like that
right i think that's
that could be challenging however i must
i must say i was uh
you know and i still am an out and out
sort of
search guy you could say but um
i've learned the contract recruitment
model and that was from
carl and i absolutely love it and
um just this year has been incredible
because
i kind of got my contract book up to 40
000 a month
really yeah during covid um
and and that's like we've got quite a
number of runners out
and i loved it because it was a breath
of fresh air i was like right right
it's way more like yeah yeah more fast
paced getting on site
obviously carl is a you know contract
recruiter entrepreneurial guy had done
serious amount of contract work
but and uh i've learned so much from
carl
for the contract piece and i absolutely
love it um because
you know i've just done two deals like
this week i mean normally like i'm doing
eight deals in a whole year
yeah yeah i definitely love it as well
the contract stuff
yeah so really quickly then so a lot of
people
maybe through this period or whatever
but there will be recruiters that listen
to this that do want to transition into
retained
yeah right so like have you had people
come into your team before that has
never done retain before and then they
have to
be retained have you has that happened
before or not yeah
so yeah really quickly then let's like
what are the main challenges that you
see
the recruiters i don't know may perceive
themselves or assume or
find difficult to go from not doing
retain to do and retain like why why do
because
people find that difficult to do that
transition so like from your perspective
like
why why do you think recruiters sort of
find that challenging and um
yeah it's a great question i think that
the first thing is is
uh you you if you peel back the onion
skin it's
do they actually ask the client can they
be retained
and that's number one like number one
by asking that you'll have even way more
opportunities than you think yeah first
of all actually
ask the question because a lot of good
contingent recruiters they've got a
great relationship with a client
but they don't know they do retain so if
you don't ask
you don't know so ask the question um
the second thing is is um you you need
to be
perceived as being niche um
a lot of recruitment companies it's
quite broad in what they do
and if you're broad then why would the
client entertain you
that that's the key thing if you
generally are just doing one market
that's the market you operate in then i
would say that the only challenge
not to do retained is just
not by asking the question um because
that's that's the main thing that i see
with people coming in and i said well
look did did you actually ask the client
uh oh no no well our company don't do
that but would your company take the
business yeah yeah of course we'll
ask the question yeah so just quickly on
this because
the common thing that i hear from
recruiters when on this conversation is
okay blaney i can ask but what's the
difference between retained and me
just doing it contingent um i'm worried
about if i don't deliver
and these things right so what like if i
say to you okay blaine i didn't ask but
what's the difference
yeah yeah sure um i mean you you've got
to back yourself
100 you've got to have that mindset that
you're going to deliver
because if you don't deliver then
there'll be big
big problems and challenges for that
that client relationship moving forwards
um because when you're obviously
pitching for retained businesses
you know you're the go-to partner for
that role you're going to fill it
and you'll do whatever you take to fill
it i'd say so you got to back yourself
100
um on the retainer you've also i think
that
the key thing is is you've really got to
understand
the brief from the client so the vacancy
you know does it exist i i use the
phrase purple squirrel to people all the
time
you know because a lot of clients they
just are looking for something that
doesn't exist or it's too skill says
brought into one
for obviously just one salary and i
always say to him listen i can't find
this you know it's like me going to
richmond park and looking for a purple
squirrel
and they laugh but it's a great analogy
because a lot of the time
clients always want something that
doesn't exist so you've got to be known
as that market specialist that can
educate them on what they need
the other thing is is i'd say you've got
to be able to
justify why you should be retained and
you've got to use
like technology around you so you know
there's
there's tooling like which isn't cheap
you know like linkedin talent insights
is a great tool there's obviously
horsefly as well which is another tool
that you can use that basically
takes all the data of the role that you
need
puts it all into a very nice glossy pdf
and tells you where the club where the
candidate might come from where the
company
how hard it is to find that person
yeah i would say you've got to you've
got to offer a service
um if if you're going to be retained um
especially at a bald level
because otherwise the problem is is it's
probably going to be quite challenging
to to win it
yeah so so only thing on this and then
we'll we'll
move on yeah you just said if you don't
deliver there'll be big problems
yeah so well you you lose the client
relationship yeah exactly so
let's just talk about that for a second
because i think this sort of potentially
happening is what stops a lot of people
asking
right yeah so like have you had that
happen before
and how did you resolve it or how did
you
overcome like talk to us a bit about a
time that
maybe that happened and what actually
happened yeah yeah so i had it once
before
um it was the second year into my
recruitment
career um i was working on a role in
germany
and um we found we found the lady
and for it and she was going to
do around a two-hour drive every day to
frankfurt she was totally
you know sold it to me and the client
that it was possible to do
and then in the end what happened was is
that um
for some sort of strange reason she sort
of said that she wasn't able to do it
it was like within the first month um
and what happened was the client was
like well
you know you told me she could do it
obviously she's told me
she could do it um but you know she's
we're gonna have to let
she's gonna have to go right um and then
instantly the client says you know look
we've paid all this money and
you know we understand from the terms
and conditions you know that
that sort of like the end of the road um
and he said if that was the case you
know
i get it it's not you're just your fault
but you know your qualification
should have been much better you know
he's a german guy
very senior and now you know they're
very
protest driven right and um i said to
him
okay well look you know from a company
point of view yes you're correct we
can't do anything but from a personal
point of view
um i'll backfill the role i'm not gonna
get any reward for it
but i will i'll backfill the role um
and um yeah i i what i did do
was i i went to my ceo my ass company
and he says
yeah no definitely you know go go and do
it you know fill the position
and then eight weeks later i found a
replacement candidate but it wasn't easy
because it was a really really
niche role and there wasn't many people
in the area um and unless
you've got to go the extra mile if
you're not prepared to go to extra mile
don't do retained work because it's not
fair
for your clients also it's not fair for
whether it's your own company
or you're working for a company because
you can lose business quite quickly if
you don't deliver
yeah no thanks for sharing that that's
super interesting so
what i'd love to just get your thoughts
on blaine
before we talk about blaine the business
owner is
what people love to find out or know
about on this podcast plane
is what does blaine's typical day look
like
right now that might be slightly
different now when obviously you're a
business owner there's just way more
hats to wear so maybe maybe um
when you were someone that was just
reliable for your own billings right so
when you had your
best year just yourself the typical
question that people want me to ask is
what did blaine's day what did blaine's
typical day look like how did he
structure his day when he was billing
half that 150k or less than that
compared to how it looked when he's
building 300 or 350k
what would you say with the main
difference as well so
i i think it was at the start i was
like uh sort of go in the office at
halfway
and you know leave leave at half five um
i was at the start of my career i wanted
to be in and i wanted to be
in the pub or the bar with my mates i
didn't want to stick around
[Laughter]
and i would build you know 150 180
you know without really you know
breaking too much of a sweat yeah
and then when i you know got more
responsibility for example
um you know i would be sort of
pretty much the the first one into the
office and the last one out
uh right so let's break down that day
then yeah come on
so so i i used to work
literally 20 minutes from my my house
um so i used to get up at 6 00 a.m
i used to go to the gym i had a personal
trainer at that point
so i'd go and train with him in the
morning for an hour
he'd like make me vomit and everything
else at the start do loads of hit
workouts
and then literally um swim
sauna shave in the office yeah by
sort of half past eight half past eight
to eleven o'clock
it was business development you know it
was literally
calling clients seeing what business is
out there um
speaking to them about you know their
future plans future growth etc
then i would then at 11 o'clock i'd have
a an admin
session of like half an hour then i
would go outside
normally walk across to the costa coffee
grab myself
a latte come back literally candidate
market market candidates out to these
clients that was like
you know 12 till one then go on lunch
one till two
two till five business development again
back on
speaking to clients speaking to clients
then from about five
to literally my wife used to kill me
until about 8 p.m at night
i'd be marketing candidates out because
what i normally found was
is that most recruiters are like postman
raw mao you know you don't know when
they're gonna come unless you've got
like a
time you know slot but normally you know
your postman oh okay send an email of a
cv oh well i sent a cv out yeah okay but
you know was it when the client was
expecting it no i just sent the cv out
okay great well i don't know where that
email's gone you don't know if he's got
it
he probably hasn't he gets 100 emails a
day i didn't want to be the postman
i want to be there i need to be the
fedex yeah that you get
15 minute time slot show your id
signature they
they know when you come you know you are
there with your id otherwise you ain't
getting that parcel
and i would just make sure that i was
known to be tying clients down so i'd
always say to my clients
when is good for me to send cvs to you
you know when are you going to be online
when can you give me
five minutes just to look through two or
three profiles when can you give me
free slots of half an hour telephone
calls so i could pre-book them in your
diary
yeah trust me go with me the candidates
are good i'm your trusted partner
we're gonna work in this together and i
think that was the difference that's
what took me from
180k biller to three years running
billing over 300k individually and a
practice billing over a million
that was the key thing um you know don't
be
raw male postman i've got nothing
against raw mao by the way yeah
it's a good analogy it's a no it's a
great analogy it's really good
i love that that that was that's what
that's what took me to where i am today
just be that go-to person you know uh
live and breathe your sector speak at
events i used to be
so nervous of like talking in crowds or
so just find the thing on that because i
love yeah i love that insight i think
people will get a lot of value from that
so let me ask you this question which is
the final thing on this is
i think this is such an interesting
question but
the question is that i get some from
people um or got from a couple of
people is like when you get a high
performing biller on they'd be really
interested
to know what you think is the most
important action or kpi that
you think contributed to your success
yeah
just just one yeah or like just what
comes up for you what do you think are
the most
important action or one two three
actions that you think
really thank you success yeah so you've
got to plan your day
yeah that's that's so important
organization
organization is so key um
so if you plan your day and then also
get you know a little a little
whiteboard or notes in your phone or
something like that
but have free things that you want to
achieve for that day
so planning and free free goals
and that could be little steps you know
it could be kind of you know
speak to this client or speak to
this candidate or do a video
you know uh on linkedin it could be
anything
um but business related of course but
get free things that you want to achieve
in a day
and be planned and then i think if you
if you do that
and you stick to that you you'll go far
love that so let me ask you then because
you were talking about it was one of the
questions that i
sort of put down to prepare for this
like yeah i saw that obviously you've
spoken at
a number of industry events and i think
see a lot of people that listen to this
podcast will hear people talking about
the importance of branding
and these things right and and you said
the word go to a lot of the time which
is obviously
what recruiters want to achieve that
go-to status and yeah obviously yeah
being able to speak
gaining credibility through the actual
industry and your industry peers
will definitely help you do that so i
guess if i'm someone listening to this
where i'm like i do want to have that
opportunity to
to speak at industry events or be
invited or whatever what
what what what do you think you did that
gave you that actual opportunity or to
actually get invited to speak how did
that happen
so i um i actively approached a number
of
shows um at the first you know i was
trying to call the event organizers
and i was getting fobbed off they just
wasn't interested you know
who's playing doors you know we don't
know you you work for a recruitment
company
i'm not the typical sweet spot for them
um
then i um i actually sent an email to
the
the sort of event owner and
and you know it was along the lines of
look give me a shot you know give me
uh a slot that isn't you know in prime
time
just give me a shot let me deliver my
message there's a huge
shortfall of talent i'm not here to sort
of promote
my business or my brand i'm there to
generally
talk about the industry and then in the
end they
they i broke the ice um and
i literally got my first one at the xl
um it was data center world
it was like a really not great
slot it was at the back of the room i
remember
um and the audience was fairly i mean
because it's at the excel it's fairly
large you could probably say
you know maybe 40 people for example
there but considering you know you've
got hundreds in the main arena
um it was very small but after that
for some reason um i i don't know what
it was but
loads of people after the event um was
coming up to me saying
you know blaine look it's a really
interesting point you know we're really
struggling with diversity
you know within within the workforce
we're really struggling with
um getting young people you know like
yourself into the sector
you know what what do you recommend what
do you do and the event organizers
instantly
were like all over me like a rash
they're like can you do singapore
can you do frankfurt can you do abu
dhabi can you do that
and i was like wow you know for for
someone that basically was
almost rejected from a lot of these
events now
it's like they're approaching me saying
look please don't
speak at the event yeah i love that um
you know that's great
great story that that's how i got him so
just real quick on this i think people
listening
yeah they may see industry uh see events
that they want to attend and stuff so
if i if i'm sort of sent you blaine
right so i've mapped out
ten events that i'd love to speak at
obviously i'm a recruiter a good chance
i might get rejected
what would you how would you encourage
me to approach like what would my angle
be so it seems like what you said was
like look
i'm not there to sell so that's rule
number one obviously right you're not
yeah that's number one promote your
services right
so what was the angle because obviously
you're not the data center expert you
don't get paid to do that right you're
never going to be as yeah
as those people so yeah to think that
you can talk about something as
technical as them you're going to be
worried about that probably
yeah so what was the angle then was it
like hey i speak to people all the time
and i know this is a problem
i think a bit like yeah how would you
encourage me to approach it would the
angle be
yeah well for me i mean in the data
center world it's known to be
an older industry there isn't much young
talent coming into it
because you know a most people think
data centers are not important
you know b they don't even know what
they are you know i think cloud and they
look in the sky for example
but it's like it it's about really
you know finding there's always a
shortfall in every single sector
yeah um and it's just about finding
what's the shortfall and you know can
you add value to their show
if you can then they'll have you on
board
the key thing is is just you've gotta
know what you're speaking about so i had
a nice little glossy deck
one pager sent it to them this is what
i'm gonna cover
this is what i'm gonna do here i am
um and you know have a good shot window
as well i mean
social selling's big now um you know
i've been big on linkedin for a while in
terms of not like
big influence or anything like that but
i just use linkedin a lot
um i publish content that i think is
relevant for my target audience
and um you know i think the event
organizers look at that as well
you know and recommendations help
recommendations have really really
helped me throughout my recruitment
career
um
yeah i know i think that's that's a
really good point i think just
the only point i would add is like yeah
as a as a recruiter if you listen to
this and
want to have that opportunity to speak
and be more involved in your industry
then yeah don't forget the amount of
people that you speak to
in that industry compared to the actual
people in that it's like a few things
exactly
how many sort of c level people you
speak to over a year compared to how
many
ceos speak to other ceos in that year
it's going to be double triple group or
that so actually
the value that you bring is is those
insights right it's it's that well
actually yeah
you're the fifth ceo that i've spoken to
this week that also shared this
challenge oh really that's interesting i
thought it was the only person
right and and yeah those insights that
you can bring to the table
and be the facilitator right and sort of
exactly
bring that out so okay so
last question on um
in terms of before you start on this
business just because
when you shared your your daily plan
there was a lot of time for business
development
so for you personally what's been the
most effective method for you to grow
your client base
in for the business development side
yeah yeah like you can you can obviously
refer to
how you do it now whatever but in your
experience in your journey so far like
what's been
the most effective method for blaine to
drum up business to grow your clients
yeah sure
uh meeting people face to face before
covered
and i was known even if i wasn't booking
a client i would
always meet everyone face to face
i think i think it really helped me
because you can look people in the eye
you know and you can they really get to
know blaine as well
uh not just so easy to fog people off on
an email or a phone call
but what was the what was the what was
the this is why you should sit down with
me even though i've got
no jobs to talk to you about anything
like that like why how did you get them
to
actually sit down with you i think yes
it was the work i've done in the sector
so obviously i was known for doing a lot
of projects i was very active
on like i say social media linkedin and
you know event shows um also
speaking to multiple people daily
because i enabled my reach was huge
because i would do so much business
development
so i i was like you know the information
gatherer
and i found out about things that they
didn't even know was going on in the
sector so when i'd sit when i'd speak to
someone say look
you know you should speak to me you know
i know what's going on in the industry i
know these projects are coming up and
this is like
real information it's not made up and
they would instantly
sit back and think wow you know you you
really do know your subject
look let's let's have you know a half
hour meeting sure
um and that that that was the key thing
to me just know your industry and the
business will come
yeah okay so what's been what's been the
most unexpected thing for blaine then
since
having a recruitment business that's
happened so far
staff talk to me what do you mean
try just trying to find the right staff
is really really challenging because um
look you know we're a startup
recruitment business we haven't been
around long haven't got a track record
like
you know some some of the bigger
businesses especially where we are um in
monument
you know there's lots of other big
recruitment companies around
um and that's just been the real
challenge just you know trying to grow
the recruitment business and and just
you know consultants work very
differently to
maybe how i've worked in the past and
it's just kind of just
just seeing who culturally fits for the
business because we're still very small
um
and and that's been our biggest
challenge so far and i think it's
everyone's challenge
just finding good staff um
and people that genuinely want to do
recruitment as well because
we've even been speaking to some
graduates and it's quite refreshing
actually
um you know some some of these
individuals that i met i was
like really wowed by them you know it
was that they were bringing something
different
and and new ways and new ideas
and not just going for the traditional
um rolexes fast cars and lots of
incentive trips that recruitment is
known for
so what what is it like and you can
obviously refer to your
time being the leader and these things
but even more so now like what is it
that you actually look for in i don't
know you're probably working this out
still but like in terms of like what are
the sort of non-negotiables for you when
thinking about
the sort of recipe for the the culture
that you want to build but most
importantly
the recipe you're looking for in people
that you think can um
have the best possible chance of being
successful in in the environment that
you have
yeah i think it the key thing is is just
people that are
open to new ideas and
there are certain individuals that think
that you know
this way that they've done it is the
only way and they're not
they're not just not open to change and
we've found that a lot you know we'll
look you know okay well i've worked at
this brand this is how we do it
and you know this is the only way it
should be done and it's just really just
trying to just find consultants that are
open
and i want to learn new things so many
people i speak to
you know just because they've built 250
or 300k
you know they feel that you know they're
the sort of
daddy now you know there is no other way
and this this is my way
and no other way and we've found that a
lot
and there's a lot of arrogance
yeah just exactly just being open you
know i love learning new things i think
it's so important you know just
keep an open mind you know i'm not the
best recruiter out there it's so
important i could learn stuff from
some of my delivery team and you know
i'm i'm still very much on the dance
floor right you know i'm not like on the
balconies looking down at everyone
you know i'm there you know i i want to
be part of it
and it's about finding people like that
as well because the level we're hiring
at we're trying to hire practice leads
and
you know a lot of them you know it's
about okay well i want to you know i
want a team of five six people
you know um i want this i want that it's
like a bucket list that they expect
yeah and why it's obviously
through recruitment mentors what one of
our values is always be learning
it's it's the first one on there and
like it's interesting because a lot
obviously i guess it's because of the
the people that i'm not speaking to but
a lot of people really resonate with
what you're saying like
and and generally have the open minds to
always be willing to learn it's not
everyone obviously but i think
why do you think people are close-minded
or even
yeah prepared to learn new things
i think i think what it is is that some
you know
if an individual's been in recruitment
for a certain amount of time
obviously they get they they get their
own way of working
and they feel that well this is working
so why change it you know why fix it um
because it works but it might have
worked way
in their last company because that's how
they worked but then
in a startup environment it's really
important to just be entrepreneurial
but also be you know like a big family
right
you know um and not just be sort of
sitting on the balcony all day and just
looking down
i think yeah you've got to lead by
example
it's pivotal well i think having the
open
having the open mind is typically there
would be some humility that comes with
that
right like if you're someone that has is
open then there's a good chance that
you'll sort of have a bit of humility to
be like
actually yeah blaine is has three years
less experience i mean actually yeah
he's got a really good idea there or
even be open to that
exactly i mean it's a mindset thing
isn't it you know it's it's like with
anything
and it's just you know if you can just
adjust
and just be open and you know just try
and let learn new things
and then you you might achieve stuff
that you never even knew that you could
achieve before
yeah what what's been the um the biggest
positive so far
since taking this leap because obviously
you've been in the employed environment
for over a decade right yeah
a leap of faith that's required so like
what's been the
biggest positive so far this year big
biggest positive
was um we hired an individual and
it was from a big agency before and he's
come
in um he's already done two deals in
about
five weeks and both of them bills were
yeah yeah both of them deals were with a
client i knew
um and i had been working with i just
wasn't working in that
division of the technical side i was
doing the sales
side and uh the feedback was was
you know we we we really like him um
and we can trust him and it was then
words
we can trust him for me i just was like
take a step back and think wow that's
great because if i can build a
a search business an agency whatever
people would like to call it
if i can build it on trust then that'll
be a huge milestone for me because
trust is uh not not the most used word
in recruitment
yeah for sure so i've got five questions
for you to finish this but before i do
we're just talking a bit about mindset
there like
for you personally what's been the sort
of best piece of advice that you've
received that's impacted your mindset or
has helped you mentally
oh best best one i've got
um i think i think the best the best
piece was um
a client said to me before you know be
open
for change and that was the best piece
of advice
that i ever had it was a really senior
exec
at google and that was really really
it it hit me and i thought yeah this is
this is so important i think i i just
that just sort of clicked with me
actually like actually
one of the benefits out of working in
the markets that you do that i didn't
think of actually is that
you probably get to speak to some pretty
impressive
like successful people but not just
around the success but
people that are self-aware people that
have been on their own journeys that
actually you could probably learn a lot
from which is what you just said right
yeah i mean i've got about 10 different
mentors
from that are all between 50 and 70
and have all run global businesses um
and i speak to them once a quarter
and i take 45 minutes of their time and
it's
absolutely amazing and it's been great
i love that so i have to ask you about
this because this is something that i
get asked a lot and then i'll ask you
these five questions but
for anyone that wants to be in that
position maybe not 10 but one or
whatever but like how how did you get
yourself in that position to
get that time in with these people a lot
of people don't know how they know they
want to mentor but have no idea how to
approach
a mentor how did you go about that
yeah i mean the fact that i know again
it's just
sounds like i said the same thing but
just just ask people
um because most people would be open to
it you know literally half hour 45
minutes of their time
um how did you approach it i think it's
the how how
it's like how do i ask is the challenge
so all of those were clients that i've
delivered on projects for
so they're all industry people that i
know
um and you know i've just asked them for
advice you know
i'm a young young guy you know and
hopefully up and coming
and uh you know i'm i want to learn new
things
and also you know i would love some
guidance
and they say any time blame you know
i've never been rejected says i will
look i can't do that
um generally people people will
and give you time yeah especially if
it's coming from the right
like it seems like that was just
actually really genuine right if it's
coming from the right place i think a
lot of people would say
yes yeah yeah exactly it's you know
all it is is you know half an hour it
could be 15 minutes you know
um and it could be about anything it
doesn't just have to be work related
yeah no i love that that's awesome i've
got five questions for you
all right brilliant first one is
if you could change the industry what
would you improve
uh i would improve the the trust of
recruitment in general um i think
recruitment
has has a bad name or certainly did have
a bad name it's getting much better now
but yeah i would just improve the the
trust in the industry
you know because uh we're not all bad
people and i think we get slaughtered
sometimes
yeah i love that so this can this so the
next question like this could be
um an audio it could be something you
watch or whatever but the question is
like what book have you read that has
had the biggest impact on you but that
could be a
could be a podcast it could be something
you've watched but like what what have
you sort of consumed that's had the
biggest impact on you
yeah so i i um i watch a lot of
tony robbins um i've watched a lot of
these clips and seminars and stuff like
that
um i actually want to do the the one
where he was in the excel
where you sort of walk across the fire
i've done that one
have you done it okay yeah yeah yeah i
wanted to do that yeah
yeah so tony robbins been a big one for
me um
that's i don't know if you're reading
anything but
audio book but i would def i read um
when i sort of
started on this whole sort of
self-improvement development journey
one of the books i read quite early on
was his book called awaken the giant
within and and that's a great book
and it's actually a lot of the things
that he talks about live event
so i would definitely okay yeah yeah
i'll i'll get that i'm not i'm not a
huge reader but if it's on audio
so next question if you could write
a linkedin post that could be seen by
every single
recruitment consultant across the world
what would you want it to say
oh that's a tough one
[Laughter]
what i want it to say um
i think i i think if i was so if it was
what just
targeted for recruitment consultants
um i i would typically say
say to them all of them to you know back
themselves a hundred
because i i speak to so many people that
have so much self-doubt
and i i it would be along the lines of
that healthy mind one
you know get up in the morning healthy
mind and back yourself
you know you're good at what you do um
so many people hide
behind a big company um and sometimes
all the brand takes all the credit but
it's all about the individuals and
that's what we've built wanted on pete
you know individuality is
our strength and uh yeah that's that's
that's what i would say
you know back yourself love that
what did you spend your first biggest
commission paycheck on
yeah my my my ex-ceo would laugh at this
it was a it was a rolex watch ah here he
is
what rolex did you get it was a rolex
watch
it i i've done quite well because it was
actually a stainless steel
rolex daytona um that i actually
um before i get robbed after this
podcast i actually sold
sold it about a year and a half ago
and um i think at the time i paid around
9 000
and i sold it for 22 000. oh decent
that's obviously the good thing about
those watches in there that they
actually
can grow in value yeah but my wife at
the time when i was buying that watch
and she was not she was not so happy
i wasn't pleased but she was pleased
because it gave
it got the funding got some of the
funding we've uh wanted
so it's good last question
what what is the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career plan
so i would i would love to just build an
agency full of open and trusted
consultants
for me that's the the the most important
goal
um i just want a really good agency that
people trust and really value
um however big or however small it is i
just think it's so important to do a
good job
love that plain it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you no no
great great